les services de réanimation qu'ovide 19
concentrent les cas de plus gras on y
trouve souvent des personnes qui
souffrent déjà d'autres pathologies
une étude du ccdh et c'est le centre
chinois de contrôle des maladies a pu
compiler des milliers de données
première conclusion les patients sans
problème de santé initial ne
représentait que 0,9 pour cent des décès
le chiffre grimpe immédiatement lorsque
les patients sont atteints
d'hypertension artérielle
il représente alors 6 % des décès or
c'est en martinique un mal très répandu
près de la moitié de la population est
hypertendu +2 42% selon l'étude canaris
chez les personnes atteintes de troubles
respiratoires chroniques ou d'asthme
le taux de décès observés par les
chercheurs chinois montent à 6,3 pour
cent pas de chance 12% des martiniquais
souffre d'asthme contre 3 % dans
l'hexagone
autres facteurs de comorbidité le
diabète les malades diabétiques
présentait dans l'étude chinoise un taux
de décès de 7,3 pour cent
or le diabète touche environ 30000
martiniquais avec un taux de prévalence
deux fois supérieur à la moyenne
nationale
le risque grimpe encore en cas de
pathologie cardiovasculaire plus de 10%
des personnes qui en souffrent et sont
décédés selon les chercheurs chinois
là aussi cette pathologie est bien
représentée en martinique
au final près des trois quarts des décès
du co vides sont intervenus chez des
patients souffrant de comorbidité alors
même qu'ils ne représentent
le quart des malades du coffee de 19 les
autorités sanitaires françaises classe
par ailleurs dans les personnes à risque
des profils particulièrement sur
représentés en martinique les personnes
âgées de 70 ans et plus alors que la
martinique est particulièrement
vieillissante notamment dans le nord
atlantique les personnes atteintes
d'obésité morbide
alors qu'en martinique plus d'un adulte
sur quatre est obèse et les personnes
souffrant de maladies rénales
alors qu'il ya deux fois plus de
patients dialysés ici que dans
l'hexagone
en résumé les personnes déjà fragile par
rapport au kobus 19 sont nombreux en
martinique
elles n'ont pas plus de risques que les
autres d'être infectés mais si c'est le
cas elles ont plus de risque d'en mourir
une raison de plus s'il en fallait pour
prendre toutes les précautions
nécessaires